jamais pensé
que je pourrais conciliaire des quêtes
écran que ce soit disparue il ya 35 ans
mais pour beaucoup de québécois rené
lévesque le politicien le chef d'état et
le simple citoyen est encore vivant est
maintenant bien présent dans l'espace
public celui de la place du spectacle à
montréal l'idée de faire redécouvrir
rené lévesque aux nouveaux arrivants aux
jeunes pour qu'ils puissent être
capables de saisir l'importance un petit
peu de de sa contribution au québec tous
deux anciens ténors de notre québécois
et d'autres ont rendu hommage à cet
homme d'exception si rené lévesque
aujourd'hui comme toujours deux des
verts qui n'est pas sûr n'a qu'une
figure du passé qui est quelqu'un de
très actuel mais on veut les mots-clés
aujourd'hui ensemble c'est important de
rendre hommage à quelqu'un qui a servi
le québec durant tant d'années qui a
tellement apporté aux québécois et aux
québécoises
on a vu de la carrière extraordinaire de
cet homme humble avec de grandes idées
ouvert sur le monde en cet après
quelqu'un qui est replié sur lui même
une autre cérémonie a eu lieu en son
honneur en gaspésie là où il a grandi
santos de voir qu'autant de gens se
souviennent de lui et sa mémoire est
bien bien observer et à longueuil le
groupe de paix qui a même tenu à le
célébrer en famille et après une semaine
où comme des petits longueuil de taillon
on n'a pas été appelé pour me dire on
s'ennuie de rené lévesque l'exposition
sous rené lévesque est accompagné d'un
court métrage lui rend hommage et sans
verser dans la complaisance affirme l'un
des auteurs est ce qui nous intéresse
ici c'est particulièrement
le côté humain commenté ce que 1 être
comme rené lévesque entre dans
l'histoire en étant ce qu'il est c'est à
dire un être parfait avec des défauts
des qualités des sautes d'humeur des
moments de dépression c'est également un
rappel aux plus jeunes et aux nouveaux
arrivants de la place qu'il occupait
dans notre histoire récente
je crois que c'est important cette
histoire pour qu'ils comprennent ce
qu'est ce qu'on a vécu puis comme on a
dû se battre
pourquoi de la continuer à ce papa de 45
ans qui joue à montréal rené lévesque on
peut dire que c'est celui là personne
qui illustre le mieux qui nous sommes
les québécoises et les québécois les
normands grondin radio canada montréal